and let's read this is your story about
is this woman a Karen the answer is No
hmm no they're trying to they're calling
her Karen and there are a bunch of
videos coming out like this where
they're it's people start filming and
they're like you're a Karen you're Karen
and there's people don't like what hi
I'm sorry what's happening she really is
not a Karen this lady no no she was she
was being actually polite like look I I
I don't want to fight I'm sorry that
you're upset with me right now I'm just
trying to leave it's like I was like wow
how does this and then boom so the quick
kinda escalated really quickly yeah yeah
the the quick context is basically this
lady's walk in at Chipotle
apparently she bumps into this
fifteen-year-old girl the girl then says
excuse you and the family starts yelling
at the white woman the video starts with
the white woman being like please just
like let me go to my car you're blocking
me and they're yelling apologize
apologize and she's like I'm I'm sorry
you feel that way you know you're
blocking my car then the husband comes
over like walks up they move out of the
way she gets in the car and then they're
all screaming and yelling and filming
then I guess the mother goes behind the
vehicle as they're the van it's our
trying to leave and then hits it I think
three times like bangs on it like oh
you're trying to hit me now but she
clearly walked it in front of it's
totally you know water behind the
vehicle they were just trying to leave
and then she hits it several times and
then the white woman jumps out and
that's where we see this picture she
pulls out her gun and it looks like
she's so this is another trick that
that's really interesting uh trigger
discipline Oh check it out check it out
they're they're saying she aimed the gun
right at the woman because in in in this
photo in this snip of the video it looks
like the gun is pointed straight at them
and in reality she actually had the gun
aimed slightly downward you can you can
argue that it's right or wrong or
whatever but it wasn't pointed directly
at them in in her face yeah the woman
was holding her phone at you know chest
height while she was filming and so with
the gun being pointed down it looks like
that's just a perspective issue that's
you know and actually it kind of looks
like she's she's yelling at the woman
and she's like kind of looking this way
and her guns aimed down to the left a
little bit - yeah like kind of off to
the side a little bit so this woman you
know basically hits the car you can see
in the full video she jumps out and says
get back get the F back and the woman
keeps walking towards her Oh
oh you're gonna pull a gun I'm gonna
close er to you yeah how we're she's
like getting away from her she's backing
up - back to the other side of the van
screaming screaming get the F back yeah
and then she finally lowers the weapon
gets in the car and then you hear the
people filming like crying saying these
white people are racist
they're police yeah but interestingly
the one of the first things you hear is
from this white woman when they're
surrounding her and screaming at her
this they're saying we're gonna beat
your your a we're gonna we're gonna beat
you up or whatever and she's telling her
husband call the police call the police
now and they didn't and they should have
so after all this is done they get
arrested so this is the update right
here let's take this out insider reports
a white woman who pointed pointed her
gun at a black woman has been her 15
year old daughter outside a Chipotle has
been arrested
I guess whether or not she actually
pointed at them this is semantics they
say video of the confrontation in Orion
Township Michigan was posted to Facebook
the woman's husband has also been
charged with felonious assault the
Oakland County Sheriff's Office said in
a press release Thursday afternoon that
they investigated the incident and
arrested the woman and her husband and
that their names will be released after
they're arraigned Tequila Hill told the
Detroit News that the confrontation
began when the woman now facing charges
bumped into her 15 year old daughter
Michaela green green and he'll demand an
apology and proceeded to call them an
ignorant and racist as the woman walked
to her car a man presumably the ones
husband got out of the vehicle and told
Hill and Greene who the F do you guys
think you are who do you who do you
think you guys are and then she said you
can't just walk around calling white
people racist why people aren't racist I
care about you and I'm sorry if you had
an incident that has made someone make
you feel like that no one is racist how
about that huh is that not an apology
for what happened I'm sorry I'm sorry
you had an incident that made someone I
mean it's I mean it's not an apology for
bumping into the person which is what
they were demanding from her like this
is the problem is they're always running
more it's so in its entitlement like I'm
owed everything that I want I gotta say
man I wouldn't be surprised if she
actually said sorry about that yeah and
they said no no say you know but I
started filming like actually like oh
excuse me you know it meant like no no
we don't want to excuse me I want an
apology yeah I'm giving a bad I'm giving
the benefited out of to the woman with
the gun because of the video because it
shows she's very calm saying please
absolutely so I'm worried about the
it all started she said something like
she bumped into the daughter and then
they're like excuse you and she's like
oh sorry
and then they're like no well we want a
real apology yeah that's my bias not a
throwaway apology like that's my
speculation and bias to be totally fair
but based on what I saw her maybe maybe
you can argue that it was an S it was it
was too much in under normal
circumstances right over to Exeter
vehicle with her gun and yet but we're
seeing like you said earlier we're
seeing people getting shot in their cars
these aren't normal when they're
actually antagonizing her and and
threatening to beat her up
yes she's around her vehicle she was
trying to simmer the situation down like
look she had her hands up like whoa you
know like look I'm not trying to you
know piss anyone off she's like I'm just
she just got in her car she's like I'm
just getting good mcard she's like look
I'm sorry I'm sorry that this has
happened like this close the windows and
it's like okay how about we speculate to
the most speculative degree we can
speculate
I love speculating like she was holding
her stomach this one this what I was
this what I this is what I thought was
I'll say it yeah okay so I mean I don't
know but I've I have a lot of women that
have been pregnant and and in my family
and I've seen the the protective nature
when a pregnant woman I'm not saying she
is pregnant but she was holding her
belly and kind of like keeping back
holding up holding her hand on her belly
and I don't know if she was pregnant or
not but her stance and her defensive
nature like trying to calm it all down I
don't know I don't know I don't know if
she was I don't know if she is and I'm
sorry woman if you if you were or
weren't rather there's such a perfect
offensive situation
I know so you're pregnant I'm not
pregnant ah so you're fat oh it's not
like she looks like well she just walked
out of Chipotle so she could be she
could have had she came out with her
belly no baby
she she just what she said baby over
stuff over stuff double meat extra
avocado yeah and she's holding her
stomach I am so fall out his bar yelling
at me no but I I know that that hold
though you're holding your belly someone
if you protect important stuff it's like
I've seen I get that you know just be
her trying to protect her stomach in
case they're gonna try and hit her or
something so I don't know I was clearly
being
feeling attacked Manny I mean you even
said it that they were gonna beat her up
they said they said yeah maybe she had
take a big dump that's assault maybe
maybe she had to you know go number two
yeah she's sitting there and they're
surrounding her and she's thinking to
herself like oh man I got a good five
minutes to make it to that that golden
throne and these people are blocking my
way you're going with the burrito baby
side I'm going south barks chipotlaway
Joe where apartment oh I don't know
though Hartman complains that he loves
Chipotle but he can't figure how to get
the blood stains out of his underwear
[Laughter]
anyway no but in all seriousness you
know I think you're not the only one who
thought that okay like people have gone
around yeah she could just be guarding
her stomach yeah who knows and I'm not
gonna understand stood it seemed like it
I don't I don't know anything yeah I'm
just going on what the full context of
the video itself I think was a defensive
position I don't think is anything
related to pregnancy really I think it's
just like protect your soft underbelly
from predators you know I mean yeah curl
up into a little ball and then roll away
yeah well check this out here's what
they say they say Hill stepped back as
the couple got into their car and rolled
their windows up but it's a driver
backed out of the vehicle she hit the
back of it believing she was going to be
struck this is the craziest thing to me
how the media is framing this
yeah that's insane she walked back there
and you hear oh they tried to hit me
yeah they were pulling away from the
situation you bolted to get Ryan sebab
man leaving yeah you were trying to stop
them like what what did you want to
happen what was the what was your goal
you know what was your goal you wanted
something like this to go down now
here's what's scary because of what's
going on around the country I would
argue I would not argue what she did was
inappropriate okay
in my earlier segment I hadn't seen the
full context of what happened but I did
mention that hey man look if you if you
hit someone's vehicle if you if you go
behind their car whatever you start
hitting on it and they jump out with a
gun maybe you should pay attention to
the news yeah because if they have seen
the the mass shooting in Louisville if
they saw the the 300 rounds fire that
that SUV and in in the Chas yeah or the
guy in Provo who ran
and shot some somebody for no reason
just for driving you got on so so the
question is without seeing the full
context even in the way they frame it
you know is it going is it is it going
to be considered unreasonable when even
the woman not admits she hid the vehicle
she struck the vehicle thinking she'd be
hit well then okay so at the very worst
case we can say bad hair day huh better
day you thought you're gonna get hit you
didn't realize she didn't know you were
there and then she panicked and because
literally ran behind total you can see
it I know in the full video it's like
it's very clear she runs back there to
try to stop him to try to be like oh you
hit me she yells it they tried to hit me
it's like what the woman with the gun
yells don't jump behind my car right
makes me so mad because this article is
saying believing she would be hit right
she did X Y & Z and I'm like no no no no
my readers don't assume what she was
thinking
that's what mainstream media does all
right well how about we check out what
the Washington Post said yeah I love
what checking them I'm super ready for
this yeah he's gonna make your blood
boil she's got the gun on me
video shows white woman pulling pistol
on black mother daughter in Michigan Oh
way to spin you ready for this yeah
first the white woman bumped into
tequila Hills teenage daughter then her
husband seemed to try to hit the black
Michigan mother with it with their
minivan and I'm just moments later found
herself in a suburban Detroit parking
lot staring into the muzzle of a pistol
oh this woman aimed her weapon at Hill
and yelled for - move back you effing
jumped behind my car woman said later
shouting back the F up the startling
confrontation which was partly caught on
camera Wednesday afternoon quickly went
viral overnight as of Thursday afternoon
video the confrontation had been viewed
about 12 million times on Twitter I am
deeply disturbed by an incident last
night where woman pointed a cocked gun
at another one during an argument the
behavior is unacceptable Oakland County
Executive David Coulter said in a
statement Thursday now yeah the woman
she actually she [ __ ] it's like she's
ready man
but look how the media plays it that's
insane
they've framed it in the worst possible
way now it's crazy you go to reddit.com
slash
all are slash are slash all reddit just
banned the Donald and too
thousand subreddits right-wing LGBT it
is not a right-wing place right and I'm
sitting back you know we're like we're
just finishing dinner and I'm looking at
my phone and I'm scrolling and I open it
up and like one of the top posts on the
front page know is here's the full video
of what happened in Michigan and I went
what's this like the full video people
have been uploading short clips where
the only thing you see is the white
woman pointing the gun screaming get
back
right so somebody uploaded the full
version and it made it to the top of
Reddit and in the comments everyone's
going like woah this is the family cross
not lying
definitely yeah and then the crazy thing
is so I'm like I read through these
comments and they're all saying things
like that the woman was clearly scared
and threatened they said they're gonna
beat her up they hit her car yet she had
a reasonable fear of harm well maybe it
doesn't justify pulling out a gun but if
someone threatens to cause you physical
harm and then surrounds your vehicle
maybe you get out and tell them to back
up so you can get out of there and
that's exactly what she did right
especially back up right now back up and
they did she got that one after a minute
shirring towards her right but into when
she finally started backing up she was
like okay got back in the car and they
took off yeah it's like alright so
here's what she probably wanted to have
happen so I'm scrolling read a little
bit more I'm scrolling and then I come
across a graphic from a camera which
some bird it was from but it was it was
a screenshot of a bunch of different
reddit posts that were all taking things
out of context and they were like do
better and the comments once again were
like I keep seeing the sniped version
the short version yeah and when you
watch the full thing you're like man
this lady was trying as her hardest to
keep everything calm and get out of
there she was and so why did she draw
the weapon she's one woman surrounded by
three or four other people screaming at
her refusing to let her leave and
threatening her yep so she's there
trying to get the car out
no one goes behind the car starts
hitting it they can't get out so she
gets out with her gun and says get away
from us yeah so the other thing that we
I don't think we've talked about is that
her two daughters were in the car too
so I think she had her two daughters
with her oh wow seriously the girl who
the woman who pulled the gun who pulled
the gun half the reason that she was
probably this defense is because she had
her family in the car not surprising at
all right trying to keep it calm trying
to try to simmer the situation down and
leave yeah they wouldn't let that happen
she's saying they were all trapped
Nicholas yeah you know scares me about
this but they're straight-up telling me
you can't protect your business you
can't defend yourself you have you guys
seen I tweeted this out
shout out to Seamus of freedom James oh
my goodness that's right video and I
don't know if you guys have seen free to
Freedom Tunes but you really should
check out freedom tunes on YouTube it's
really good so the one of the one of his
latest cartoons it's making fun of the
st. Louis couple who are holding their
guns wrong he's holding it backwards but
a bunch of anti fuh and and far leftists
march onto his property and then he
yells get off my property they see him
holding the gun and they start crying
you know and they're all crying and then
it shows like people on the news crying
and then MSNBC hosts are crying and then
he goes okay okay I'll get rid of the
gun he puts it down and then he goes now
and then also an anti-fog goes get him
and they run out yeah beating him up you
know that's that's kind of what it feels
like you've got like like we mentioned
before we started segments there's a
video going around where this guy gets
out of his car and he walks up to his
business it's a new he just bought it
and there's blacklivesmatter signs all
over it and so he just starts taking him
down then he gets ambushed by two dudes
screaming at him like why are you
tearing down our signs are you racist
and the guys who confuse like no it's my
building I'm taking the signs down and
it's they're screaming at him this guy
clearly has no idea what's going on you
know there's a sign in the window that
said no man has ever been shot doing the
dishes right old-school joke reference
to making your wife happy like she won't
shoot you you're doing the dishes they
thought it was a reference to following
the law or something they went nuts and
and and there's this man it's white dude
in his white woman I just standing there
confused like hands on the side not
saying anything looking at each other
like what's happening right now right
and the guy's saying like you're racist
you're Karen you see videos like this
and then you see that video of the woman
who got followed by the dude yeah man
she's shrieking and like shaking screen
owner me you're gonna call me a Karen oh
yeah yeah
it's messed up and a lot of people said
she overreacted and I'm like maybe or
maybe she knows what happens to people
when they get called Karen and he
followed her home yeah followed her on
door I think
that that is the reason why she was more
afraid yeah like the first he backed up
behind her too so she couldn't get out
of town - yeah that's that's frightening
I like that that's frightening that's
why people are buying guns yep it what
is it what's a 8.3 million so far a lot
since March well it won't matter it
won't matter because if you're on your
own property and a large where people
break on your private property you pull
your gun there now the the the I guess
the local prosecutor or whatever is
trying I don't know exactly which
position it is they're searching for a
crime they and they've said they're
thinking maybe fourth degree assault or
intimidation or some like that but yep
so they trying to find if they don't
have anything yeah so they have nothing
so it's Russia gate again well well let
me twist this they can just make it up
and they can be like we're gonna go for
this yeah and try and try in court well
now you have this woman you think about
this people can surround you threaten
you with physical harm and scream in
your face hit your car hit your car
surround it and you can't defend
yourself
that's messed up we're headed we're
headed like this apparently so it's like
in the UK that you know we're talking
with the other day someone will break in
your house and then you try and defend
yourself and now you're the criminal
just let them let them let them break in
I guess unless you're lucky enough to
get the cops there before anything bad
happens but yeah man what happens now
what they'll say is and they and they
said it a lot oh but you didn't have to
kill them right and it's like yeah bro I
mean very few people actually want to
kill people you know I mean exactly that
goes yeah but a lot of these stories you
hear about self-defense issues where
someone dies they're like why didn't you
try and do something else and it's like
Adrenaline's pumpin she literally tried
to leave yep she was trying to leave and
they wouldn't let her she was trying to
say please let me just go like you know
I'm sorry what you're all set I'm trying
to leave now that I think is we tried to
leave now that I think about it the way
we would kind of gone through everything
she did the right thing I agree yeah
especially that she had kids in the car
I didn't know that it's like so she's
you being attacked she didn't know what
that pound was or what if she thought it
was a gun or a brick or something yeah
if you're if you're gonna start
attacking my car that I have my family
in here yep get out get out of the way
yeah that's like you know I believe I
don't blame her at all
the video starts with her surrounded and
she's saying please you're blocking me
from my car yes around let her leave
they're saying we're gonna beat you up
yeah assaulting her then finally her
husband gets her in and then when they
try and leave the woman goes around and
hits the car so she can't you know what
choice does she have right just sit
there and pray and wait that things
deescalate right or get out and defend
yourself it's not only that but she had
her finger properly and the gun seems
like she knew she was doing and it was
aimed a downward and slightly away from
the people yep from from what we Elian
get back man she started backing up yeah
exactly more space and now they've
charged her with felony assault and her
husband it's insane morality policing
man is what I'm talking about
police know that if they charge the
family or don't arrest her they'll have
a riot so they will violate your rights
if it means preventing civil unrest I
don't like it at all yeah me neither man
I like civil rights I like we've all
seen the video when you've got a clear
consensus like this where even the
lefties on reddit are saying straight up
like nah man that's not cool it's not
why is she being arrested now maybe the
cops are like look you'd be fine charge
I'll get dropped or whatever prosecutor
will say new evidence has come to light
or something like that maybe or maybe
they'll look for a political prosecution
and they'll say if we if you don't plead
there's gonna be riots so you know
please be better yeah we'll see we'll
see what happens I mean we'll see it
what they do and who actually riots
because of this BS yeah oh come on dude
they want to give them a reason they'll
write they've been riding non-stop no no
I'm not talking about the people who are
already rioting well who are not writing
you mean what you mean like the regular
people who are getting sick and tired of
everything yes yeah oh is anybody gonna
riot no that that she's got it she's got
arrested I think she they're gonna let
her go I think I think they're gonna
look at this video and be like oh I
disagree you don't think so you think
they're gonna you know Chicago stick
Chicago just released 817 black lives
matter demonstrators who had been
arrested 817 I'm sorry they're now
released they had all of their charges
dropped
were they protesters or were they
rioters protesters oh so it was
low-level nonviolent protest related
offenses okay 800 there so you're gonna
get a $2,000 fine can you into a party
in New York and they're gonna let all
these people violating CDC guidelines
and City lockdown orders I don't I don't
like anything de Blasio is doing I think
my kago I know
I know but you referenced the the thing
in your poem oh that's New York State oh
yeah the whole state is gonna be like
yeah I thought it was just the city oh
it's the city too but yes the city
they're they're locking down a gun so I
mean I also don't like what de Blasio to
it but sure we'll talk about Cuomo - you
don't like anything and you doing either
do you know who drop the charges on
these 817 people who Kim Fox
you know Kim Fox's know who's that she's
the prosecutor who dropped the charges
on justice Millette ah interesting
interesting how the people who aligned
with her ideology have all their charges
so hold on and you said well it's
because our budget just can't handle it
can't hit it wait so it's ADA it's
low-level offenses you give a fine say
50 bucks gone yeah
no no they're letting them go no issues
dude when when you engage in civil
disobedience there is a small price to
be paid yeah I know I worked for tons of
nonprofits and they say you know there's
a there's a line where it's kind of gray
where you are breaking the law but
everyone kind of rolls their eyes and
says we get it right and then you get a
slap on the wrist charge and you go home
to just drop them out right now I'm not
I'm not I'm not super worried about them
dropping the charges for the most part
but you look at what's going on with New
York and and Fort Worth mm-hmm and they
drop the charges as well in instance a
Fort Worth it was writing charges yep so
welcome to morality policing they
arrested this woman on a normal day she
would have been arrested I really don't
believe so there had been no arrests
they would have said ma'am you can't
surround a vehicle bang on and threat
you're gonna beat somebody up she she
defended herself nobody got hurt she
went home go home
I've actually been physically attacked
when I was in New York you go and the
cops were like you're okay right now
right and I was like I was like sure but
the guy attacked me go home mm-hmm and
I'm like this dude actually hit me and
they're like everybody's okay right and
I was like I guess but shouldn't he get
isn't it a crime go home they don't want
to do it they won't do it you got to
think about like did the cops really
want to go through the motions of
arresting somebody over something like
this
they didn't want to but they got a viral
video situation on their hands and
they're like you gotta do something look
I don't want to deal the riot so you're
under arrest innocent till proven guilty
isn't here right here about
I tell you about that dude damn dicks in
Vancouver I think it was Vancouver
sounds familiar well he's like an indie
journalist guy on YouTube okay and he
went to some rally where an tyfa song
they tried calling the nazi or whatever
okay and then they were basically
getting up in his face and blocking his
camera the cops tell him to leave and
he's like I didn't he's like these
people are harassing me and they're like
we don't care and then he's like I'm not
leaving because these people are
harassing me so when the cops arrested
him Wow really he was the victim he got
arrested that's where we're going man
that's great because the like I said the
police are like dude you can't expect me
to stop 30 people right now in my own I
can stop them by arresting you I'll
violate your rights I'm good easy right
tik-tok right exactly yes exactly being
bullied you don't like all these other
people bullying you get banned yeah it's
easier to ban the victim than it is to
ban the bullies yeah well we keep the
bullies would make money you know you
banned the victim just one person yeah
this is one person huh this is where
we're going this is where everything is
headed I like it and it's and it's in it
and it really is predictable but the
next step is gonna be I mean look I say
the next step but but in that in that
story with Dan he didn't commit any
crimes yeah it's one thing if like okay
this lady did pull up plot a weapon yeah
there is an argument about whether or
not you're allowed to do that right and
the cops have erred on the side of I'm
gonna just give to the protesters right
well I mean there she was clearly being
baited the whole time her husband got
arrested dude yeah what did he do I
won't talk to them yeah he was in the
driver's seat so they're clearly going
after them for protest ideological
reasons yeah it's true now you've got
prosecutors who are favoring an ideology
you can't go to church but you can
protest now you've got what is it
there's like a viral there's a viral
image going around from LA apparently
someone asked the mayor they were like
you've got all of these protesters out
in the street you know and protesting
and you're telling us we can't go out
for fireworks or whatever like how can
you reconcile that double standard yeah
can't can't course not I don't know what
he said oh the reality is no you can't
you can't it's very obvious right
happening that there's no in there right
now in the United States finest i yes
but i would say it's it's worse than
that okay it's malicious
his nefarious you're right Kim Fox we
know who she is we know what she tried
doing for justice Millette this dude
staged a major hoax that hit the entire
country yeah and people were going crazy
over it mm-hmm and when he gets charged
these crimes she's like you're good just
go home I'll drop it
yeah that's not incompetent that's
Melissa now eight hundred and seventeen
demonstrators who were violating CDC
lockdown orders state lockdown orders
charges all dropped don't worry about it
so there it is they're all just chess
pieces it's all just pieces on a board
for somebody they're telling you right
now that if you want if you want your
freedom if you want to be able to
arguably your freedom if you want to be
able to go outside if you want to be
able to go to the park and hang off your
friends you must bend the knee to our
ideology to our to our new religion yeah
it seems like and if you say no they'll
arrest you if the mob comes for you this
is what worries me in the in the
Vancouver story again not the United
States they they surround him they
attack him Dan gets arrested in this
story you have fight breaks out she's
threatened this around her vehicle she
draws her weapon she gets arrested
Rashard Brooks Atlanta the cop is trying
to arrest a guy who was caught driving
drunk passed out in his vehicle your car
running starts fighting him sealed your
taser heels the Taser she wins it at him
and then within a split second that
dewdrops weapon shoots in three times
immediately renders aid now he's facing
potentially the death penalty felony
murder
yes insane so what comes next the mob
will show up to your house they'll start
protesting the place will say what
happened and they'll accuse you of some
fake ridiculous crime and the cops will
arrest you think about what goes on with
this title nine stuff have you have you
ever have you heard a lot of the stories
about the college town online stuff like
not a little bit false accusations and
accusations what would happen if you
woke up you could wake up one day and
the cops are knocking on your door and
they're like we have an arrest warrant
for an Adam Craig lers at you and you're
like yeah what for and they're like rape
and you're like who and they're like
you've been accused turn around we're
not gonna tell you the name we're gonna
tell you anything you're under arrest
it's messed up then you just find
yourself in jail then all a sudden the
medias running your name like crazy all
because it takes one and what happens is
these these false accusations
there's no penalty for the women who
make the false claims typically I just
get away I know someone personally
though we talked about it yeah
that went to jail for two years and then
she was she felt guilty and finally
admitted it to someone else
and though my friend got out and she cuz
she lied she was just upset that he
broke up with her the justice system
just crumbling just claimed it and
nothing happened to her she didn't she
didn't getting in trouble he lost two
years of his life because he broke up
with her and she just screeched about I
imagine he'll get expunged
yeah it did think about it it doesn't
matter that's two years of his life is
gone so think about it she's in trouble
at all think about how easy it is right
now that some woman will accuse you the
mob shows up to your house they easily
find it you know then the cops show up
and they're like what's going on and
they demand you must arrest him because
he's a criminal the cops are gonna be
like okay it's easier just to arrest to
do than deal with this and so the walk
in they'll arrest you and you'll walk
out confused not knowing what's going on
and then they'll be laughing the whole
time thanks for checking out this clip
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune into this channel subscribe hit the
like button or check us out on iTunes
and Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you